SPEAKER 1: Let's welcome
Mr. Kailash Kher.
[APPLAUSE]
[? Kailashi, ?]
welcome back to Google.
You were here about
four years ago.
KAILASH KHER: A few
years back, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Could you tell us about that?
KAILASH KHER:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH].
So we always intend to do
something for the mankind,
for the betterment of our
surroundings and society.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
So many ups and downs,
the lows and the highs
I had seen in my
[? formatives. ?]
So because of all
that, many learnings.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
It in itself is a mission.
I don't count myself
like, oh, I'm a rock star.
I'm single.
So many times I talk
like these guys.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
In America or in
other countries,
they sometimes ask with a
curiosity, oh, are you single?
Yeah, I'm single.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SPEAKER 1: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
KAILASH KHER:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
So you can take a nap
wherever you are-- in the air,
under the ocean,
wherever you are.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
We all go through ecstasy,
bliss, and some kind of high.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Sometimes you feel this way.
You don't say though,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
You know this much material is
God has [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
How you can be a loner being
amongst millions of people,
and how you can be-- so many
people being alone, too.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[LAUGHTER]
[SINGING NON-ENGLISH]
[APPLAUSE]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[SINGING NON-ENGLISH]
SPEAKER 1: Let's roll
the video, please.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
SPEAKER 1: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
What was the inspiration?
Why are you talking
about love at this stage?
KAILASH KHER:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH].
[LAUGHTER]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
I was cruising there.
I met this Filipino girl.
Neither she knew
any of my language.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[LAUGHTER]
That is called ascending--
ascending [? women ?]
[? nodes. ?]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[LAUGHTER]
[SINGING NON-ENGLISH]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SPEAKER 1: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
KAILASH KHER:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH].
[LAUGHTER]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
You have to walk
like this straight.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Now we are coming up with
our online academy also.
So slowly, slowly we are
also a big step further.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
KAILASH KHER:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH].
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
They're pure, like
love music is pure.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
KAILASH KHER:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH].
Actually, you'll be surprised.
That song is basically
a romantic song.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[SINGING NON-ENGLISH]
I want to see your
beauty, how you kill me,
because I'm too much in
love with you, how you kill.
You are such a beautiful killer.
And I am your admirer,
the biggest admirer.
That is the thing.
SPEAKER 1: Very nice.
KAILASH KHER:
[SINGING NON ENGLISH].
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Tell us a little bit about that.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
KAILASH KHER:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH].
We always have the
privilege to live with that.
I observe.
I come from a very,
very simple background.
That's why my observations, my
grasping senses are very sharp.
I don't get carried away by
all the luxuries I live with.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Or, oh, hi, how are you doing?
Oh, I'm doing good.
How are you?
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[LAUGHTER]
I saw many observations.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SPEAKER 1: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
KAILASH KHER:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH].
SPEAKER 1: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
KAILASH KHER:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH].
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[APPLAUSE]
KAILASH KHER:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH].
SPEAKER 1: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Let's hear it for
Mr. Kailash Kher.
[APPLAUSE]